because everybody's always like oh you
love christmas like
why do you love christmas i'm like
because it was i always wanted it to be
great as a kid
um and it was always somehow foiled
by people when i was growing up because
i didn't grow up with the money or the
things to have
much but i always loved it and then
certain siblings or people that i don't
know anymore
would come over and ruin it
ruin it every time so as an adult i was
like they will never
never do that to me again and then i
wrote all i want for christmas as you
you know a while back and it was the
first christmas song that i ever wrote
and then when it took on this sort of
life of its own it just
i was always into christmas i was always
doing my own thing but it also just
helped every year like oh i get to
listen to my own christmas album and
people were coming up and telling me oh
we listened to your christmas album in
in july or whatever and i'd be like oh
that's so great but i've grown to love
it more and more
um just from a standpoint of like you
know it's
it's my little song that so many people
talk to me about it's
it sort of kicks off the holidays for
them so
you